صباح الخير
[تصفيق]
اول مره بوقف قدام جمهور لاحكي كان خلال
دراستي بالمعهد الوطني الاداره العامه 50
شب وصبيه هن زملاء اكثر
وقتها وقفتوا لطاوله المحاضر مسكت الكرسي
بايدي مثل عم بتخبى وراها كان الموضوع
رهب كتير كبير
[موسيقى]
مع الناس والوقفي معه الوحده من التجارب
الممتعه والمفيده بالنسبه الي لك دوما بكل
حدث جديد ما بقدر ما اتذكر التجربه الاولى
الرهبه الاولى والوقت الاولى بمسار المهني
يمكن هذا احلى شيء بيبقى من التجارب
المنعيشه هاي القصص يلي ما منمل نحكيها
نرجع منعيشها من جديد ونحن عم نحكيها
ونحكي شو اثرت فينا وشو غيرت فينا انا
بالشارع مبارك ناشط مدني من مدينه حمص
بحمل شهاده عليا بالاداره العامه ومختص
بمجال الاداره المحليه والتنميه وضمن مجال
اختصاصي اشتغلت على اكثر من محتوى معرفه
من دراسات تقارير ودلي معرفيه ومحتوى
تدريبي ضمن مجال الاختصاصي ايضا كان عندي
الفرصه لحتى اتنقل بكتير المناطق بسوريا
من درعا جنوبا الى حلب شمالا من الساحل
للداخل الذي كلها كانت فرص كثير مهمه لحتى
اتعرف وبتشتغل وتطلع مع الفاعلين المحليين
على واقع مناطقنا المحليه بعمق بتحديات
التنميه المحليه بهاي المناطق متميزات كل
منطقه اخرى
كتير من الدروس كانت من خلال هذا الموضوع
ما ممكن لاقيها بسهوله بين الكتب والمراجع
لكن الدرس الاهم اللي تعلمته هو انه العمل
مع مجتمعاتنا المحليه مو بسهوله اللي نحن
بنفترضها انه افتراضاتنا النمطيه وصورنا
المسبقه لازم نحطها على جنب
وانه مسار العمل مع المجتمعات المحليه هو
مسار طويل متعب معقد مفتوح على كل
الاحتمالات والنتائج وان التنميه المحليه
هي مالها وصفه جاهزه بنطبقها بكبسه زر انه
مثل هيك افتراض ممكن يهدد شغل كامل من
الجهد والتعب بالفشل ويزيد من احباط الناس
الثقه بيننا وبينهم
السهل الممتنع سهل الممتنع هو التوصيف
الاقرب الي لما بحكي عن التنميه المحليه
وهذا التوصيف هو نتيجه كثير من التجارب
اللي مريت فيها وخلتني وقف وفكر بالقليه
اللي نحن بنشتغل فيها وبنبني تدخلاتنا مع
الناس وكيف بنستسهل بكثير من الاحيان اليه
العمل مع مجتمعاتنا المحليه وكيف بنستسهل
احيانا امكانيه الوصول للغايه اللي عم
نسعى لها
المساحه الامن المساحه الامن هي اول قصه
رح شاركها معكم اليوم
خلال ورشه عمل مع المجتمع المحلي بمنطقه
ذات واقع اقتصادي وخدمي سيء تبع لظروف
الحرب اللي مرت فيها هاي المنطقه
اطلعنا استماره مشاركه لحتى نضمن شفافيه
الوصول لاستهداف اكبر فئه من الناس كان
بالتاكيد في معايير الاختيار المشاركين
والمشاركات بالتوازي كانت تحضيرات على
اكمل وجه عم تصير من المدربين المجسرين
المحتوى التدريبي المتطوعين كل الماجسيات
ومكان تنفيذ هاي الورشه اخترناه في قاعه
بعيده عن المنطقه اللي استهدفناها قاعه
مجهزه فخمي مشهوره فينا نقول بالمدينه
اللي عم نشتغل فيها
باليوم التاني بتيجي وحده من المشاركات
وبتقول لي بتعرف
انا ورفيقتي سجلنا على استماره المشاركه
واثنيناتنا نقابلنا لكن هي ما قدرت تيجي
بتعرف ليه لانه ما عندها شيء مناسب تلبسه
ولا تيجي لهون
مو كتير صعب نفهم القصب من وراء هالكلمتين
يلي افترضناه تحضيرات على اكبر مستوى كان
واحد من اكبر تحديات هاي الصبيه وهذا مثال
على كثير من الناس
اللي بتحس بالرهبه والخوف واحيانا بالضغط
بيمارس عن قصه او غير قصد من هيك اماكن
كان يمكن الاسهل بالنسبه لنا او بالنسبه
الها بشكل اساسي لو انه كنا بمكان اقرب
لهذه الصبيه يعني الاسهل لو انه اخترنا
مكان اكثر ببساطه وما بيمارسة هذا النوع
بالضبط
لكن الشيء المهم بالقصه اللي انا عم
بحكيها هو الناس الناس اللي صارت اكثر
جراه على انها تحكي وتعبر عن رايها وهاي
لحظه كتير حقيقيه المهم انه نحن نلتقطها
ومهم انه نطور شغلنا وتدخلاتنا مع الناس
بناء على ذلك
كلنا بنعرف الحكمه اللي بتقول بدل ما
تطعميني سمك علمني اصطاد دوما المثال
الجاهز بالنسبه لنا لما بنبلش مشاريع
التمكين الاقتصادي والمشاريع للدخل دائما
هي المقوله بنبلش فيها شغلنا بوحدي من
مؤشرات التدريبيه لمشاريع المدرعه للدخل
كنت عم تستحضر هذا المثال لحتى اشرح
للمشاركين اهميه الانتقال من مرحله
الاغاثه لمرحله التمكين الاقتصادي ودعم
المشاريع المدره للدخل
واحد المشاركين بيقول لي ليش شفته اذا في
سمك بالاول
ولما طلبت منه يستوضح اكثر
قال لي اذا علمتونا الصيد اعطيتونا العده
وما كان في سمك انا راح ابيع العده لاكل
بحقها
هاي مانا حكايه بس هاي قصه كثير من مشاريع
التمكين الاقتصادي والمشاريع الداخلي بلشت
وما قدرت تكمل هاي قصه كثير من البرامج
لماذا نضمن استدامه
كان لازم ندرس طبيعه المنطقه اكثر كان
لازم ندرس قدره السوق المحليه على التصريف
تحديات لها علاقه بالتمويل بالتراخيص
بتامين المواد الاوليه بتامين الايد
العامه وكل شيء بيضمن استدامه هاي
المشاريع باختصار كان لازم نشوف انه اذا
في سمك
ناس اليوم صارت اكثر اهتمام وعي ونضج
بالشيء اللي عم نعمله كرمالهم لذلك واجبنا
نحن اليوم نكون كتير مباشرين حقيقيين
مثلهم للحرري نعرف كيف نطور شغلنا معهم
وكرمالهن
اذا رحت على البحر مو معناها انك سبحت
ما ممكن انسى هالعباره ابدا
بالاستراحه بوحده من ورشات العمل
احنا دوما الاستراحه بالنسبه لنا هي فرصه
للحديث مع الناس تكون مساحه اكثر اريحيه
لحتى نتعاطى معاهم اكثر ونتعرف عليهم على
مناطقهم بعرف شو في عندهم توقعات من شغلنا
شو في عندهم ممكن بعض المطالب او
الاحتياجات نقدر انه نساعدهم فيها واحد
المشاركين بيقول لي ابني اذا رحت على
البحر مو معناها انك سبحت
ولما سالته الاصل بنحكي
قال لي ابني لحتى تسبح لازم يكون وقت
سباحه ولازم تعرف تسبح ولازم يكون معك عده
السباحه
لا تزعل مني بس انتو اليوم بتجوا على
البحر وبتكتبوها بتقاريركم انكم اجيتوا
على البحر وبتفكروا انتم بتفكر الناس انكم
سبحتوا بس الصراحه للوقت وقت سباحه وما
بعرف اذا معكم عده الاصلاح او حتى بتعرفوا
تسبحوا اساسا
اذا رحنا على البحر مو معناها ان نصبح
اذا حكينا تنميه مو معناها ان اشتغلنا
تنميه
ولحتى نشتغل تنميه لازم نعرف تنميه ولازم
يكون معنا ادوات التنميه ولازم يكون وقت
التنميه
الناس اليوم محبطه وزاد على احباطها هذا
الواقع السيء عم تسمع تنميه اكثر ما عم
تشوف تنميه لذلك حقها الطبيعي انها تحبط
وتسال وحق علينا انه نكون اكثر قرب منها
وكيف نحن نحنا عدسه نعبر عليه
طبعا انا ما بقصد التعميم او التجريح بكل
اللي ذكرته انا موجود ضمنا هاي مواقف
متعرض لها كلياتنا نحن بنشتغل بالعمل
التنم
بس مين نحن
واذا كان هذا السؤال جوابه سهل بالنسبه
لنا نحن اللي بنشتغل بالعمل التنموي نعرف
بعض بنقعد مع بعض بنحكي مع بعض وبنشبك مع
بعض بس يا ترى الناس بتعرف مين نحن
وحده من افتراضاتنا بان الناس بتعرف ان
احنا بالوقت لازم نكون اقرب من الناس
بحاكينا وبشغلنا وكيف الاسرى والهدف اللي
نحن عم نشتغل عليه
قصدي الاخيره اللي راح شارككم اياها هي
قصه شخص ساعدته منظمه دوليه بترميم بيته
كان كتير سعيد وهو عم يحكي كيف هاي
المنظمه ساعدته بترميم البيت وعم يشرح
الجهد اللي تقدم لحتى ترمم بيت عمله
اخر شيء قال لي
انا بعرف اسم المنظمه بس لا بعرف من هي لا
بعرف شو بتشتغل لا بعرف شو هدفهم ولا بعرف
شو فيني ساعد كل اللي بعرفه انه رممولي
البيت وغيروا لي حياتي لما رجعوني انا
وعيلتي على بيت عمري ولما قلت له ببساطه
كان فيك تسالهم اكيد رح يجاوب قال لي يمكن
انا ما بعرف كيف بدي اسال بس هني اكيد
بيعرفوا يحكوا عن شغله لا انا سالته ولا
البيت اترمموا هذا المهم
مهم يترمم البيت اكيد والبيت هو دلالي على
النتائج الايجابيه ليش شغلنا بالعمل
التنموي بس المهم اكثر من وجهه نظري كيف
نضوي على شغلنا ونعرف عن حالنا وعن الهدف
اللي بنسعى له للناس اللي عم نشتغل معهم
بمسار التنميه والعمل مع المجتمعات
المحليه مو بس مهمه المكان اللي نوصله
الطريق اهم بكتير لان على هذا الطريق في
كثير من المواقف والتجارب اللي نتعلم منها
في كثير من الناس المترافق معهم الشغف
والاصرار على احداث اسد حقيقي وفي كتير
ناس بتمر مرور الكرام في دروس كثير مهمه
نتعلم منها نتعلم شو يعني مساحه امنه
مساحه امنه لهم مؤلمه لا تزيد تعب الناس
بس عادي تتعب كرمالهم هذا دورك ومسؤوليه
انت ارتضيتها لنفسك وتعبنا كرمالهم هو
اللي بيخلينا ندور لهم على السمك مو بس
نعلمهم الصيد ونعطيهم العدهم
نتعلم كمان انه اذا حكينا تنميه مو معناها
انه اشتغلنا تنميه معناها لسات مع الشط
ولحتى نسبح لحتى نشتغل تنميه لازم يكون
معنا ادوات التنميه ولازم نعرف تنميه
ولازم يكون الوقت الصح وانه اذا حكينا تني
مو معناها الناس عرفتنا لازم نكون اقرب
بحديثنا للناس كيف نعرف عن حالنا وعن
شغلنا لازم نكون اكثر جراه نترك الطاوله
والكرسي ونكون اكثر اصرار ومعرفه بكل خطوه
عم نخطيها وبس تركنا الكرسي راح يكون في
كثير من النجاحات وراح يكون في اسرع حقيقه
على الارض راح نفتخر فيه وراح نوقف نحكي
قدام الكلمه شكرا
[تصفيق]